foreign
[Music]
River to explore one of the oil blocks
designated for auction by the government
we're on our way to meet the village
chief who's about 15 kilometers or so
away and a little bit of a roadblock
you know you get a very real sense of
the depth of feeling here just by
driving it on this track through these
little communities because we keep being
mistaken to being part of the oil
exploration project and quite a lot of
people the adults have come running out
shouting get out of here we don't want
you here we want to keep our forest
leave our forest alone and it has got
quite aggressive as well
oh
reaction
my first reaction is that people would
have to kill me and then kill our people
before this happens the life of people
depends a hundred percent on the forest
here any kind of drilling activities
would be devastating
foreign
[Music]